[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa al espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia del cob y 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa vamos a hablar de argentina
este país superó esta semana los 100 mil
muertos por kobe 19 las cifras superan
cualquiera de los peores escenarios que
tenía previsto el gobierno de ese país
cuando comenzó la emergencia sanitaria
veremos también cuáles son las
restricciones dictadas por el gobierno
para hacer frente a la variante delta en
ese país en la consulta con el doctor
pérez hablaremos entre otros temas de
los efectos secundarios que ha producido
la vacuna de janssen algunos pacientes
inoculados han desarrollado casos del
síndrome de guillain barré veremos qué
es lo que dicen los estudios médicos
también hablaremos de ese debate mundial
que hay sobre una posible tercera dosis
de alguna de las vacunas o si no es
necesario ya lo veremos en minutos y con
nuestros corresponsables veremos en
detalle cómo está la situación en
estados unidos en donde avanza
rápidamente
la variante delta y en donde ya se habla
también de la pandemia de aquellos que
no se quieren vacunar
por otro lado hablaremos de uruguay allí
más de la mitad de la población ya está
completamente vacunado con las dos dosis
de las vacunas contra el cob y 19 pues
comenzamos y lo hacemos directamente con
la consulta al doctor carlos eduardo
pérez él es médico infectólogo asesor
científico de france 24 ustedes ya lo
conocen él está con nosotros para
explicarnos diferentes temas que tenemos
en la agenda del día de hoy doctor
gracias por estar con nosotros como
siempre un gusto conversar con usted y
comencemos hablando por esa alerta
emitida de eeuu que dice que la vacuna
de janssen de acuerdo a algunos casos
estudiados en podría tener algún vínculo
con el síndrome de guillain barré que es
lo que se dice en la comunidad
científica y médica sobre este tema
santiago dentro del proceso de la
vacunación lo más importante es lo que
se llama la farmacovigilancia eso que
indica que nosotros debemos saber cómo
es el comportamiento de las personas
vacunas el síndrome guillan-barré es un
síndrome neurológico de parálisis
plácidas se paralizan los músculos es
muy rara la enfermedad y se observó en
100 personas en más de 12 millones y
medio de personas vacunadas el riesgo
para esto es muy bajo a cerca de cero
punto 400.000 0 8% de probabilidad de
tener el virus sin embargo es una
situación que existe ese documento y
tenemos que estar los médicos atentos a
las personas que han recibido este tipo
de vacuna doctor hablemos ahora de ese
debate que hay en la comunidad
internacional de si es necesaria o no
una tercera dosis de algunas de las
vacunas contra el hobbit 19 mientras hay
algunos países en donde no han puesto la
primera vacuna donde no ha llegado un
primer lote para empezar a inocular a la
población hay otros países como por
ejemplo israel que ya han comenzado
darle a algunos de sus ciudadanos un
refuerzo precisamente porque tienen unas
condiciones médicas especiales pero
también hay otros países como el reino
unido- como eeuu y también chile que ha
avanzado mucho en la vacunación en
américa latina en donde han comenzado
precisamente a estudiar si es necesario
o no una tercera dosis
elmer pro en el tiempo nos va a
determinar cuándo es el mejor tiempo
para vacunar y si se necesita un
refuerzo las discusiones hoy está
centrada es con las nuevas variantes y
si la vacuna es efectiva o nos hace nos
protegen más hacia la paz variando en
israel
la tercera dosis a las personas
inmunosuprimidas no es para toda la
población y la discusión está abierta es
en el sentido de que la tasa farm acepta
puede recomendar en algunos casos la
tercera dosis pero los gobiernos no han
encontrado evidencia suficiente para
implementar la norma en este momento no
se recomienda una tercera dosis pero
esta es una situación cambiante y
debemos esperar en el que probablemente
uno o dos meses para poder establecer si
es necesario una tercera dosis con qué
vacuna y en que el grupo de personas por
ahora hay que mantener es vacunarse
completamente y mantener las vidas de
disciplina social que ya hemos conocido
durante este tiempo depende en resumen
entonces dependería de cómo irán
evolucionando las diferentes variantes
que tan agresivas pueden llegar a ser y
dependiendo de eso se podría
entonces una posible tercera dosis pero
sería entonces en el mediano plazo
doctor otro tema destacado esta semana y
que incluso algunas personas se
escribieron a las redes de france 24 es
ese anuncio que dio una alerta mejor que
dio la o ms que dijo que puede haber
precisamente más variantes incluso más
agresivas que el mismo coronavirus
inicial que tuvimos al inicio de esta
crisis sanitaria es esto posible que
tendría que suceder entonces para
llevarnos a ese posible escenario donde
enfrentemos variantes mucho más
agresivas
lo primero que tenemos que en el claro
es que mientras más personas vacunadas
menos personas se pueden enfermar y al
enfermarse menos personas mayor
probabilidad menos probabilidad de
generar las variables es lo que sucede
santiago que en algunas partes del mundo
como mencionábamos política por esta
inequidad en la repartición de las
vacunas la pandemia ha aumentado en sus
números y al aumentar el número
infectados se incrementa el riesgo de
que haya nuevas variantes y las nuevas
variantes pueden ser leves o pueden
tener una característica de mayor
agresividad de sus iniciarte eso no se
puede predecir sin embargo siempre que
haya más infectados hay ese riesgo por
eso el llamado es al equidad y la vacuna
a la masificación de la vacuna sin
restricciones y que la vacunación no
debe ser para uno sino de ser para todos
o si no no finalizamos la pandemia
doctor y para terminar quiero
consultarle por un tema que anunciamos
la semana pasada fue esa autorización
para el uso de emergencias de la vacuna
cubana abdalá siempre los desarrollos
médicos y científicos allí en cuba
generan todo tipo de controversias
precisamente en la
comunidad médica y científica a nivel
internacional desde su punto de vista
como analiza el desarrollo de esta
vacuna cuáles son sus opiniones al
respecto que sabe de los estudios
científicos y médicos que hay sobre ella
la información que tenemos es alguna
información que todavía no está
documentada en revistas de alto impacto
sin embargo pues algunos comentarios han
llegado hablan de su efectividad que ya
han realizado los estudios de fase 3 sin
embargo pues necesitamos revisar los
datos para poder asegurar su efectividad
no hay nada mejor que cada uno de los
países desarrollaron una tecnología y su
vacuna y que las multinacionales liberen
las patentes para que cada uno de los
países que tengan la probabilidad de
desarrollar la vacuna lo haga eso hace
parte de la equidad que se debe tener en
el proceso de vacunación la liberación
de las papel es bienvenida en las
estrategias nuevas de vacunación que
sean desarrolladas por los países pero
se deben documentar completamente con
rigor científico publicarlas que los
datos sean abiertos que sean
verificables para todos grupos
científicos y así pues la recomendada
por ahora estamos es en plan de
observación y ojalá que sea un buen
desarrollo para todos nosotros lo
necesitamos necesitamos todas las
vacunas están disponibles para la pena
declarar doctor que esta vacuna fue
autorizada para ser usada de emergencia
solamente dentro de gente
'cuba todavía no tiene un uso
internacional y pues tampoco ha recibido
una autorización por parte de la oms por
lo que será muy difícil verla siendo
inoculada en otros países en las
próximas semanas por lo menos en el
mediano plazo doctor pérez muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
como siempre un gusto conversar con
ustedes aclarar tantas dudas que tenemos
en torno a la pandemia y en torno al
coronavirus al cob y 19 muchas gracias
y esta fue la cifra destacada de la
semana no es una cifra alentadora de
inmediato les digo argentina superó las
100.000 víctimas mortales por cuenta del
cob y 19 que sigue sin dar un respiro a
este país suramericano con un largo y
sostenido pico de contagios que ha
empeorado con la llegada del invierno
austral y también ante algunos casos de
la variante delta el presidente
argentino alberto fernández habló sobre
estas cifras de fallecidos y sobre los
retos que sigue enfrentando argentinas
escuchemos cada vida que se fue a cargo
con mucho pensar en mí
a todos los que han perdido un efecto en
la pandemia sepan que me van a encontrar
siempre solidaridad cariño
y profundo pesar por lo que le tocó
pero les garantizo
que la puerta de salida está acá nomás
les garantizo que nos vamos a parar en
estos meses de vacunar a cada argentino
y a cada argentina vamos a conocer más
detalles de la situación en argentina
vamos hasta buenos aires con natalio
coso yola natalio como siempre un
gustazo tenerlo en el programa tengo que
comenzar preguntándole por esa cifra por
las 100.000 víctimas que deja o más de
100.000 víctimas que deja ya el cob y 19
en ese país que más dicen las
autoridades escuchábamos hace unos
minutos al presidente argentino que
reacciones ahí también para intentar
mitigar este alto impacto en el número
de fallecidos
si hubo un momento en esta segunda ola
de kobe 19 en argentina en que se veía
ya inevitable alcanzar esta cifra que en
cualquier caso es una barrera
psicológica que al cruzarla da cuenta de
la dimensión del impacto del coronavirus
en argentina 16 meses llevó a alcanzar y
superar los 100 mil muertos para ponerlo
en perspectiva en el año 2017 que es uno
de los últimos años en los que hay
registros por todas las causas en
argentina hubo 340 mil muertes además
gran parte del impacto se aceleró en los
últimos meses en los primeros 12 meses
de pandemia fueron 66 mil muertes
aproximadamente causadas por el cob y 19
pero otras 34.000 y un poquito más de
34.000 para alcanzar y superar las
100.000 ocurrieron en tan solo estos
últimos 4 meses de segunda ola una
segunda ola que empieza a perder fuerza
aparentemente las camas de terapia
intensiva la ocupación de camas de
terapia intensiva ha empezado a
reducirse y también ha habido una caída
sobre todo desde mayo
la actualidad de la cantidad de casos
diarios reportados de kobe 19 en
argentina
natalio el gobierno de argentina se ha
esforzado por tener a raya la variante
delta ha tratado de evitar que llegue a
este país o que se multipliquen los
casos con varias restricciones y una de
estas medidas es limitar el ingreso de
personas procedentes del exterior esto
incluye también a los ciudadanos
argentinos y por eso hemos visto a
varios ciudadanos argentinos que están
con largas esperas en los aeropuertos
internacionales o incluso teniendo que
alargar sus vacaciones porque no pueden
ingresar al país que dicen sobre esta
situación sobre la variante delta y
sobre la situación de los argentinos en
el exterior
y justamente por el impacto de la
segunda ola de kobe 19 por ese temor muy
grande a que ingresé y empiece a
circular a tener circulación comunitaria
a la variante delta se impusieron hace
algunas semanas controles más estrictos
para el ingreso al país esto llevó a
restricciones por ejemplo de tan solo
600 personas pasajeros por día que
podían ingresar a la argentina con
vuelos desde el exterior esto ahora se
ha empezado a modificar y se está
permitiendo progresivamente que sean más
pasajeros ha causado una crisis una
tensión política también por las
personas que han quedado paradas fuera
del país y que tienen tienen que ser
reprogramados constantemente sus vuelos
para regresar por diferentes motivos no
todos han salido por vacaciones del país
hay personas que tal vez salieron por
tratamientos vinculados con su salud o
por otras necesidades personales y
planes personales de vida que no están
pudiendo regresar eso ha generado
tensiones y también ha generado por
supuesto un alimento más a la grieta
política constante que existe entre
gobierno y oposición en el país pero
bueno
de eso es lo que va de la llegada de la
variante de la argentina- se han
detectado nueve casos de personas que
llegaron desde el extranjero con esta
variante por lo menos hasta este viernes
y el gobierno de las autoridades
informaron que detectaron un caso de una
persona que no estaba cumpliendo el
aislamiento obligatorio una de las
personas que tenía la variante delta
cuando fueron a su domicilio no se
encontraban y las autoridades no se
encontraba en el domicilio las
autoridades determinaron iniciar
acciones penales presentaron una causa
ante la justicia y es que el gran temor
que hay en el país es que si comienza la
circulación de la variante delta a nivel
comunitario es entre personas dentro de
la misma comunidad argentina en
cualquier lugar del país eso llega en un
momento en el que todavía la vacunación
con segundas dosis es limitada no ha
alcanzado a un gran porcentaje de la
población y con segundas dosis con
esquemas completos es cuando se tiene
más garantía de de tener una protección
más fuerte contra enfermedades graves y
contra hospitalizaciones
natalio no puedo despedir este reporte
sin preguntarle por un balance de la
situación general en cuanto a casos de
contagio fallecidos y vacunación allí en
argentina cómo está el panorama
por la vacunación ha ganado fuerza tiene
cada vez paso más firme en argentina
pero el mayor desafío sigue siendo
completar los esquemas con dos dosis en
la mayor parte de la población posible a
la argentina tiene unos 45 millones de
habitantes alrededor de 30 millones son
mayores de 20 años y están entre los
grupos que de un modo u otro pueden
recibir la vacuna y de esos ya más de 21
millones de personas han recibido una
dosis pero de ese número tan sólo un
cuarto había ya ha recibido el esquema
completo de dos dosis al menos hasta
este viernes es bueno siguen llegando
las vacunas pero como vemos todavía es
lenta la aplicación de las segundas
dosis
siguen llegando como decía cargamentos
de manera consistente de vacunas sputnik
ve astrazéneca occovi shield y sin afán
que son las que se están dando hasta
ahora en argentina además esta semana el
instituto gamma leia de rusia aprobó un
primer lote de vacunas fabricadas aquí
en argentina por el laboratorio richmond
y eso debería permitir que próximamente
se están habilitando
la distribución de 1.3 millones de
componente 1 y un millón de componente 2
que se fabricó en ese laboratorio en
argentina para acelerar aún más el
programa de vacunación en el país además
el gobierno argentino alcanzó un acuerdo
con el laboratorio moderna tras una
modificación en la normativa vigente en
argentina que permitió empezar a
negociar con más laboratorios y se prevé
que lleguen 20 millones de dosis de esa
vacuna en el primer trimestre de 2020
perdón de 2022 y además sumado a eso el
gobierno de eeuu anunció este viernes
una donación de 3,5 millones de dosis de
vacuna moderna para argentinas en este
contexto la idea es que se acelere como
decía lo más posible la vacunación y el
gran desafío es completar los esquemas
de 2 dosis en la mayor cantidad de la
población posible lo más rápido posible
en el país
natalio gracias por este reporte de
acuerdo a las cifras que usted nos da
argentino le está apostando entonces a
la vacunación como la forma más rápida
de bajar un poco las cifras de contagio
y de fallecidos allí en este país
vamos precisamente a los números como
cierran la semana algunos de los países
de nuestro continente en cuanto al
número de casos y de fallecidos por
cuenta del cobi 19 comenzamos entonces
en el norte del continente en canadá
este país cerró la semana con más de 1.4
millones de casos confirmados y más de
26 mil 400 personas han fallecido en
panamá hay más de 419 mil casos y más de
6.600 personas fallecieron ya en ese
país en ecuador contabilizan más de 472
mil casos y más de 21.800 personas han
perdido la vida luchando contra el joven
19 mientras tanto en república
dominicana para el cierre de esta semana
registraron allí más de 336 mil casos y
más de 3 mil 900 personas ya se
aproximan a los 4 mil han fallecido
seguimos en el caribe para el cierre
trinidad y tobago tienen más de 35 mil
400 casos registrados y más de 900
personas han fallecido
en la ciudad de nueva york en eeuu la
comunidad científica teme por la
apertura económica también por la
resistencia de muchos de los ciudadanos
a la inoculación y la circulación de la
variante delta que ya es dominante en
ese país norteamericano las armas para
combatir estos factores siguen siendo el
autocuidado y la vacunación siete de
cada diez neoyorquinos tienen al menos
una dosis del esquema completo de
vacunación veamos
[Música]
el bronx en la ciudad de nueva york más
del 70 por ciento de los neoyorquinos ha
recibido al menos una dosis de la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 pero algunos sectores
como este todavía están rezagados es por
eso que la ciudad ha enviado autobuses
con vacunas para facilitar que la gente
la reciba coral y camargo es madre
soltera y vive cerca del lugar de cuando
vayan a la escuela quiero asegurarme de
que cuando entren a las clases y se
sienten quiero asegurarme de que estén a
salvo
su hija carmen de 12 años está
recibiendo su segunda dosis en su cara
nuestra valentía decide michelle ha
estado posponiendo la suya pero ahora
está lista en abetxuko fons un camino
que une contra la gripe siempre luché
contra eso así que solo lo hago porque
mi esposo recibió la inyección así que
dije que lo haría
han ganado los metros de la ciudad están
repletos de información sobre la
inoculación en varios idiomas
pero nueva york que se encuentra entre
los 25 estados que informan un aumento
de los casos de kobe 19 en gran medida
debido a las nuevas variantes el
fundador y director del centro nacional
de preparación para desastres cree que
eso es motivo de preocupación de las
variantes y especialmente la del está
ahora son un problema serio y una de las
razones por las que estoy muy ansioso
sobre la apertura completa demasiado
temprano incluida la de las escuelas es
que mucho de esto no está bajo control
es decir cuando tú dices que el 70 por
ciento de los neoyorquinos ha recibido
al menos una dosis de la vacuna es bueno
pero los niños no pueden vacunarse si
son menores de 12 años y los maestros no
están obligados a vacunarse así que creo
que estamos tratando con una amenaza
potencial sobre la que no tenemos
control o webber
la ciudad continúa haciendo todo lo
posible contra el coronavirus ofreciendo
todo tipo de incentivos para que sus
ciudadanos se vacunen incluidos viajes
gratuitos en metro
nos vamos a quedar en eeuu para
profundizar en la situación que se está
viviendo allí ante un nivel si está en
miami en el sur del estado de florida
nos conectamos con él para conocer más
detalles hola anthony gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa hablemos
de esa preocupación la más grande que
hay en este momento y es la variante
delta ya lo decíamos hay un alto
porcentaje de casos allí registrados en
eeuu pronto va a ser la variante
predominante que dicen las autoridades
particularmente allí en el estado de
florida
hola santiago pues si la variante delta
está causando estragos en eeuu a pesar
de que muchos ya empezaban a respirar
tranquilos en el país convencidos de que
la pandemia había desaparecido pero lo
cierto es que la propagación de esta
variante mucho más contagiosa es cada
vez más fuerte representa más de la
mitad de los nuevos contagios en eeuu y
las infecciones hospitalizaciones y
muertes están aumentando de forma
drástica en estados como arkansas
missouri texas y nevada donde
curiosamente se registra una baja tasa
de vacunación la casablanca ya está
abordando la posibilidad de implementar
una nueva campaña de vacunación
precisamente para combatir esta ola de
contagios por la variante delta de hecho
los centros para el control y prevención
de enfermedades los cdc han revelado que
el 99 por ciento de las muertes por kobe
19 en eeuu en las últimas semanas han
sido de personas no o inoculadas sólo la
semana pasada se registraron 26 mil 300
nuevos casos de coronavirus en eeuu un
70% más que en la anterior mientras que
las muertes diarias en ese periodo
con un 26% hasta las 211 antonio en el
hemisferio norte están en plena
temporada de verano la ciudad de miami
es un destino turístico por sus playas
allí han llegado numerosos turistas de
todas partes del mundo cómo está la
situación allí en cuanto a la vacunación
los casos los fallecidos en pleno pico
de las vacaciones de verano
si en florida la situación no es muy
esperanzadora y los médicos están
alertando de una tendencia preocupante
en los hospitales y es que los casos de
coronavirus casi se duplican en las
últimas semanas y de nuevo el problema
vuelve a ser las personas que no se han
puesto la dosis contra el mortal virus
en algunos casos según el departamento
de salud de florida los pacientes están
bastante enfermos el gobernador de
florida el republicano ron de santis
dice que esto es un patrón estacional y
según afirma los expertos habían pero no
está pronosticado una bajada de casos en
mayo y luego un incremento en junio y
julio algo que efectivamente sí que ha
pasado pero en florida más de 10
millones de personas se han vacunado
completamente representa casi la mitad
de la población por lo que los médicos
insisten en que hay que potenciar la
vacunación masiva especialmente entre
los jóvenes que están haciendo una vida
completamente normal olvidando que la
variante delta es una seria amenaza para
la población
antonio en cuanto al estado de la
florida en un lugar crítico por la
llegada de muchos turistas incluso ya
muchas personas allí no utilizan el
tapabocas como está la situación a nivel
nacional varias ciudades y varios
estados han tenido que retomar algunas
de las restricciones
si eeuu ha registrado un importante
aumento de las muertes y los contagios
por kobe 19 como ya hemos dicho en gran
parte de personas no vacunadas mientras
que el ritmo de las inoculaciones se ha
estancado principalmente entre los más
jóvenes en la conferencia de prensa
semanal organizada por la casa blanca-
rosell valensky la directora de los cdc
ha asegurado que la situación actual se
está convirtiendo en una pandemia de
personas no vacunadas a pesar de que el
país cuenta con suficientes dosis para
inocular a toda su población y los
centros para el control y prevención de
enfermedades están preocupados no solo
porque la gente no se quiere vacunar
sino porque quien no se quiere poner la
dosis lo hace después de leer noticias
falsas sobre las vacunas y es que la
máxima autoridad sanitaria de eeuu el
cirujano general de bec martín admitió
que la desinformación supone una amenaza
urgente en un momento en el que los
casos están subiendo y las tasas de
vacunación se han estancado marfil
también ha instado a las compañías
tecnológicas y a los gigantes de redes
sociales que cambien sus productos y
software para evitar que la difusión
datos falsos además de incrementar el
acceso a fuentes fiables que ofrezcan
datos y por supuesto también resuelvan
dudas al respecto importante de ese
punto anthony la pandemia de los no
vacunados gracias por este panorama de
la situación en la unión americana vamos
ahora con más números vamos como cierra
esta semana la vacunación en el
continente americano este es el
porcentaje de la población de algunos de
los países de la región que ya tienen el
esquema de vacunación completa es decir
tienen las dos dosis dependiendo de la
vacuna de la vacuna o una dosis pues
dependiendo por qué por ejemplo las y
novak es de dos dosis y la jansen es de
una sola
comenzamos con chile allí ya el 59 punto
83 por ciento de la población está
completamente inmunizados en canadá el
47.43 por ciento de la población en
república dominicana el 33 punto 46 por
ciento de la población ya tiene el
esquema completo méxico solamente llega
al 16 punto 50 por ciento mientras que
perú cierra esta semana con él
11.36 por ciento de la población
con el esquema completo de vacunación
bueno y en otros temas una investigación
de la organización mundial de la salud
indica que esta pandemia del cobi 19 ha
frenado la vacunación infantil el
reporte destaca que el kobe 19 podría
haber ocasionado la mayor alteración en
la historia de los programas rutinarios
de inmunización poniendo en riesgo a
cerca de 23 millones de menores de edad
en todo el planeta todos ellos podrían
contraer enfermedades como el sarampión
la difteria o también el tétano que son
enfermedades que se pueden prevenir
precisamente con un esquema de
inmunización el retroceso es crítico
particularmente en el sudeste asiático y
por supuesto en américa del sur
la oms atribuye nuevos daños colaterales
a la familia de kobe 19 la pandemia de
kobe 19 provocó un gran retroceso en la
vacunación infantil que nos hace
retroceder más de una década se estima
que 23 millones de niños no han recibido
la vacuna básica a través de los
servicios de inmunización de rutina en
2020 estas cifras representan el mayor
número de niños sin protección desde
2009 la investigación de la uem se
estima un alza en el porcentaje de
menores desprotegidos de enfermedades
como la difteria el tétano y la tos
ferina sería un 17% de niños sin
protección a nivel mundial
ingrid estos últimos datos se muestran
un aumento alarmante del número de niños
que no recibieron ninguna vacuna a los
que llamamos niños de dosis cero
poniendo en juego la vida de millones de
jóvenes el principal factor que explica
este descenso es la pandemia que hizo
que muchas familias no llevaran a sus
hijos a vacunarse por los confinamientos
o por temor a contagiarse de covilhá
y el país donde más menores quedaron
desprotegidos en términos absolutos fue
india con 3.5 millones de niños que no
recibieron la vacuna contra la difteria
el tétano y la tos ferina
juani a medida que pasamos de 2020 donde
vivimos un período de compromiso social
para reducir la transmisión de estas
enfermedades prevenibles por vacunación
a 2021 se acerca potencialmente una
verdadera crisis para la protección de
la niñez y no queremos llegar a esa
crisis
la güemes es subraya que sin medidas
concertadas el mundo afrontará mayores
riesgos de brotes de enfermedades
infecciosas evitables con vacunas como
el sarampión la tos ferina
brevemente les cuento otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa haití recibió el
primer lote de 500 mil vacunas contra el
cob y 19 con el que será puesto en
marcha el plan de vacunación nacional
las vacunas fueron donadas por estados
unidos a través del mecanismo kóvacs el
condado de la ciudad de los ángeles en
el estado de california en eeuu en
requerir a nuevamente el uso de la
mascarilla en espacios cerrados incluso
entre personas que ya están vacunadas el
anuncio se da ante un marcado repunte de
infecciones muchas de ellas de la
variante delta como lo hemos dicho acá y
bolivia recibió un cargamento de un
millón ocho mil dosis de la vacuna
jansen contra el cob y 19 vacuna que es
de una sola dosis así lo confirmó la ope
se dijo que este lote fue enviado al
país suramericano a través del mecanismo
kóvacs
dos millones de personas ya han sido
vacunadas con esquema completo en
uruguay un país que tiene 3.5 millones
de habitantes esto quiere decir que más
del 50 por ciento de la población de la
republica oriental ya está vacunada por
completo y eso abre la posibilidad al
regreso de los espectáculos públicos y
también a las fiestas nuevamente las
medidas adoptadas allí en uruguay son
objeto de estudio debido a la
efectividad que aparentemente han tenido
y yo bueno les ha funcionado a los
uruguayos vamos hasta la ciudad de punta
del este en el departamento de maldonado
en la costa uruguaya allí se encuentra a
karina almas con más información o la
karina vamos a comenzar con las cifras
las cifras son completamente claras dos
millones de personas vacunadas más del
50 por ciento de la población una
noticia muy positiva para los uruguayos
en su lucha contra el kobe 19 reacciones
allí
así es uruguay con 3.5 millones de
habitantes alcanzó las 2 millones de
personas que ya recibieron 2 dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 el gobierno
analiza la posibilidad de suministrar
una tercera dosis en este caso serían
del laboratorio pzifer actualmente los
19 departamentos del país se encuentran
en zona amarilla o naranja el país salió
de la zona roja según el índice de
harvard en cuanto a contagiados cada
100.000 habitantes el presidente luis
lacalle pou indicó que esto es un
trabajo de todos que no es solamente
debido a la vacunación que la situación
sanitaria está mejorando en uruguay sino
a la conducta ciudadana
karina y un dato que llama la atención
es que las autoridades uruguayas
habilitaron la vacunación para
extranjeros sin cédula en ese país llama
la atención porque uruguay ustedes han
recibido una gran cantidad de ciudadanos
venezolanos y también muchos argentinos
se fueron a uruguay al inicio de la
pandemia porque allí las condiciones
eran un poco mejores a las que se
estaban presentando
argentina y posteriormente uruguay cerró
por completo las fronteras y estos
argentinos quedaron allí y les tocó pues
quedarse a lo largo de estos meses
residiendo en ese país
efectivamente en uruguay aquellos que
hayan solicitado refugio o migrantes que
están en el país hace más de 90 días y
no han solicitado la residencia legal en
uruguay y aunque no tengan cédula de
identidad podrán recibir las vacunas
deberán agendar se de acuerdo a su grupo
etario el ministro de salud pública
daniel salinas indicó que los migrantes
son una parte importante de la sociedad
aportan a la misma con su trabajo y por
ende deben de ser amparados en el
sistema de vacunación actualmente las
autoridades tienen dificultades en saber
cuántos indocumentados existen en el
país y por ende cuántas vacunas se
necesitan para cubrir a esa población
por lo tanto la agenda en este momento
está abierta y se continuará dando la
inoculación a esta población
karina y para finalizar hagamos entonces
balance de la situación general en
cuanto a las medidas que están allí
instauradas en uruguay y lo pregunto
porque la variante de delta pues ya está
circulando en suramérica y los gobiernos
comienzan a tomar medidas que dicen allí
varios expertos consideran inminente el
ingreso de la variante del delta al país
es por eso que ante casos de pcr
positivo de personas que ingresan a
uruguay se están analizando estas
muestras los científicos tratan de
prevenir que esta cepa se disemine en el
país porque consideran que la situación
que está mejorando la pandemia en
uruguay con un descenso de muertes y
descenso de la cantidad de casos activos
puede cambiar como lo hizo con la
variante p 1 que ingresó desde brasil es
por eso que también hay mucho énfasis en
la frontera seca de uruguay karina de
almacén reportando los desde la ciudad
de punta del este- tanto nos un reporte
sobre la situación en uruguay gracias
karina por este reporte ya continuación
demos un vistazo a otras noticias
destacadas de la semana en redes y miren
esta publicación de los ángeles times'
lado ms fue prematuro destacar descartar
laboratorio como origen del cob y 19
esto según palabras
de la oms pedrosa jesús quien indicó que
posiblemente el virus del cobi 19 pudo
haberse originado en un laboratorio
chino y se filtró al exterior por eso
pidió a las autoridades chinas ser más
transparentes en las investigaciones
sobre el origen de la pandemia
es todo aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa nos vemos la próxima semana
gracias por la sintonía sigan con
france24 sigan cuidándose lavándose las
manos y usando la mascarilla hasta
entonces